herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
ist wieder drei ich dann wieder was
braucht mir ist etwas ernster wieder
nicht vom dfb hat auch ein bisschen was
verändern ich habe man bis nach gemacht
wenn man auch noch ein zimmer heute gibt
es wieder eine versuche nicht zu lachen
hat es und war mit youtube kakadu das
gab es zuletzt mitte reagiert diese eine
baby video angeguckt haben kann man
super super euch an machen wir was
bisschen klassischer youtube kapitel und
zwar gucken wir uns auch wieder von
galileo youtube kacke der kläffer
heftigen durchfall worden um das
nachfolgende video chat mit wo er laut
capital liegen die das lesen wieder
lichtet sich aber kein youtube kennt man
nicht irgendwelche videos aus die so das
ist überhaupt nicht mehr davon erkennen
das original zu tun es gibt auch ein
paar eigene initiative wird immer wieder
[Gelächter]
kraft und bewegungsaktivitäten wir jetzt
richtig rein und bewegungsaktivitäten
wir jetzt richtig rein
ein weltbürger verkauft
[Musik]
und einmal reiten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was beweisen immer wieder was eigentlich
hallo und herzlich willkommen videos
normal bleiben das video anzuschauen
natürlich auch berlins papa fifa wieder
sehr viel spaß macht ihr müssen sehr
beraten
eine auswahl zu treffen mit der
ministerin sehr gut